el día de cleo empieza pronto eso sí a
pesar de la hora no puede faltar un
toque de rímel y el pintalabios antes de
salir para trabajar
vanderlei es el apodo de su fiel
compañero un camión de 15 metros desde
el que recorre las carreteras de brasil
tras los controles de rutina arranca una
jornada que se prevé larga
la pasión de cleo por el camión empezó
en su infancia durante los viajes en
autobús hasta el pueblo de su madre
cerebro que estaba siempre quería estar
cerca del conductor en cualquier
vehículo en el que estuviese muy pronto
me enamoré del tráfico a sus 56 años
tuvo que superar muchas pruebas para
hacer camión era inicialmente la
resistencia de su marido y después de la
sociedad
lloré mucho por causa de los prejuicios
me decían búscate otro empleo me decían
estás quitando el trabajo a un padre de
familia
yo respondía yo acaso no soy madre de
familia and so mind familia now creo
tiene tres hijos adultos que siempre me
apoyaron incluso cuando hace 18 años
dejó la peluquería para seguir su
vocación
siento mucha libertad poder hacer algo
que me gusta cuando era peluquera me
sentía muy atada adoro todo esto incluso
dormir aquí es agradable conocer otros
lugares nuevas personas
y otros lugares que ser personales pero
no todo son ventajas la fuerza física a
veces limita su trabajo aunque con este
modelo de camión es todo más fácil
aquí no hago mucha fuerza física lo más
difícil es encajar esta lona en el
agujero ahí encima la burocracia es otro
desafío requiere una dosis enorme de
paciencia son muchas horas a la espera
de que las empresas liberen las
mercancías y hay otro obstáculo la edad
auto muy feliz es una empresa que
trabaja soy muy feliz en mi empresa
porque me aceptó en mis condiciones
actuales una señora gordita con silla
con una estética que no se corresponde
con el patrón de belleza actual drone
porque el camión no es una cuestión de
belleza y si de destreza